well look look her language is strong
but in essence of course she's correct
everyone absolutely condemns all the
violent rioters at the capitol on
january 6th goes without saying
they're domestic terrorists and the law
should deal with them and by the way
there's really nobody arguing that
that's not the case
as far as what's going on with big tech
and the democrats
they are in effect now deciding who can
say what it doesn't matter what you
think about what donald trump
trump said a day or two before the
capitol events
in essence big tech took him out they
coordinated to not only take him out so
he couldn't communicate on
twitter and say youtube platforms to get
a message out but they took him off
spotify they took him off pinterest
they coordinated a few tech leaders to
say this guy can't speak
and the message that's sent to to you to
me to everyone watching this
is oh if we can take out the president
of the united states the sitting
president of the united states
well we can take you out too and big
tech just has an extraordinary amount of
power to control
the message to control the tenor of
what's being said in the united states
and we just have no idea how the
algorithms are manipulating us
and well actually i think we do have
some idea and it's not well which is why
uh the country sort of feels that it's
actually a very interesting point about
a sitting u.s president i think you're
exactly right about that
and then the pillow guys band who's next
my pillow mike look mike is a good guy
right well that's the point mike is a
good guy it doesn't matter if every
political belief he
has falls within exactly what they say
the overton window is on that given day
uh he's allowed to express himself as an
american but now he can't be on there
and again
who will be next it's not as if they
take out one person
and then they all sit down and go okay
we solved the problem it's we take out
one person
and now there's blood in the water who
else can we take it's very interesting
the answer to this is that we need to
build some new platforms
yeah i just think we have to build some
new platforms i've started locals.com
and and that's blowing up right now
but we need many solutions to this we
can't have so much power
in the hands of a few that's what the
founders were worried about as far as
the government but now it's
in terms of even if you start a new play
you've got a long way to go to catch
some of these big tech
companies that have been out there for
years you're in la but in san francisco
they're renaming schools
washington's out lincoln's out dianne
feinstein is out
where's this hand
oh man i mean this is just the obvious
obvious extension of everything that
uh that wokeness that social justice was
bringing let's not forget i mean these
guys eventually will go for mlk
too because you know he didn't want his
children to be judged
on the color of their skin but by the
content of their character that's the
reverse
of what black lives matter wants that's
the reverse of what critical race theory
wants
so of course they're going to take out
every historical character and by the
way
barack obama himself although he is a
lefty and a progressive he should be
against this too
because let's not forget the first time
he ran for president
he ran against gay marriage so the
progressives of 2040 will gladly
want to take his statues or the obama
library that's being built right now in
chicago i believe they'll want to take
that down too one day
so you got to be careful what you ask
for this is a movement of destruction
it's very easy to destroy things it's
not that easy to build them and create
it was a 6-1 vote
one vote roosevelt middle school was
named they weren't sure if it was named
after fdr or theodore roosevelt so
you've got that to chew on throughout
the day
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell